[Música]
essa palestra começa agora mas não
termina hoje
vamos fazer o seguinte todo mundo agora
pega o celular
vamos lá todo mundo pega o celular e
coloca um despertador para hoje à noite
escolhe um horário que você vai estar
livre 789 da noite uma da manhã o meu
vou colocar traz 11 e ativa para tocar
hoje eu não poderia pedir para vocês
colocarem no modo avião que eu tenho
certeza que já fizeram isso todo mundo
pronto despertador ligado
agora a gente pode começar aqui é você
esse alvo é onde você quer chegar na sua
vida profissional pode ser um emprego
pode se abrir uma empresa pode ser criar
um projeto
então vamos chamar esse alvo dia o seu
objetivo melhor né
e esse caminho é todo o percurso que
você vai trabalhar até chegar no seu
objetivo
mas analisando esse caminho eu percebi
que nem sempre ele é tão linear assim às
vezes ele pode ser assim
ou então assim e foi refletindo sobre
esses cenários mais difíceis e mais
reais que eu me fiz a pergunta estivesse
um método corta caminho capaz de
encorajar a vocês a dar o primeiro passo
e capaz de criar atalhos para você
chegar mais rápido no seu objetivo
eu fiquei refletindo sobre essa pergunta
e fiquei trabalhando dias e dias e dias
conversei com especialistas
juntei com a minha experiência pessoal
para trazer hoje aqui de uma forma
simples um método
há duas formas para você criar atalho e
chegar no seu objetivo e a primeira
delas é através de conexões conexões são
pessoas que acreditam em você e que vão
de apontar a oportunidade sempre que
possível e o 2º batalhão é através de
idéias criativas bom mas como eu cheguei
nesse desenho foi mais ou menos assim
essa daqui sou eu comecei minha carreira
de forma tradicional
fiz faculdade e cursos enviei a prime
primeira empresa de design depois montei
minha equipe
conquistei pequenos depois grandes
clientes e abrir mais duas empresas de
tecnologia
depois de 13 anos empreendendo eu tinha
conquistado o meu objetivo
já a índia o objetivo não é chegar no
topo é simplesmente chegar aonde você
quiser chegar combinado
bom eu me sentia no meu objetivo mas eu
entendi que aquele ciclo dentro da área
de design e tecnologia tinha se fechado
para mim e eu resolvi abrir um novo
ciclo na minha vida e um novo objetivo
mas agora dentro das artes plásticas
só que a minha bagagem de 13 anos em
design tecnologia e eu não conseguia
enxergar como que ela me criar uma ponte
para chegar naquele meu novo objetivo
dentro das artes plásticas
então não me via voltando lado o início
de novo mas nesse momento antes de eu
entrar nesse estado eu pensei eu não vou
levar 13 anos de novo para percorrer
esse caminho
então vamos pensar eu tenho dois atalhos
que podem fazer chegar mais
nesse objetivo o primeiro é através de
conexões mas espera as minhas conexões
elas eram de outra área elas não eram da
área das artes plásticas então eu não
tinha conexões então eu agarrei com
unhas e dentes o que eu tinha de mais
forte que eram as minhas idéias
criativas e é sobre isso que eu vou
falar aqui hoje
quem é que acha que não tem idéia
criativa levanta a mão
deixa eu ver se vocês acham criativos ou
não pois é na maioria das vezes as
pessoas acham difícil chegar até uma
idéia criativa
então eu trouxe aqui hoje uma forma
simples e replicável pra vocês
conseguirem chegar nas suas ideias
porque eu acredito que uma idéia
criativa é uma combinação de habilidades
e habilidade todo mundo tem né
é algo que você é bom e que na maioria
das vezes você ama fazendo
vou dar alguns exemplos
a fisioterapeuta débora lima que juntou
suas duas habilidades
primeiro seu conhecimento em
neurociência e seu amor por desenhar e
começou a criar mapas mentais para
simplificar um assunto tão complexo como
a neurociência e depois que ela se
lançou nas redes sociais
a vida dela mudou ou então da estilista
empresária lígia barreira que abriu uma
moda uma marca de moda pensando no
imponderável mento feminino ela juntou à
sua habilidade dentro dessa área com a
sua habilidade de inspirar mulheres e
criou uma marca que é literalmente uma
voz e da força e orgulho e empoderamento
das mulheres principalmente mulheres
negras e essa marca já tem 15 anos
como você pode ver
às vezes uma habilidade que você tem
pode ser o seu maior diferencial
e eu acredito que todas as habilidades
são muitas
você só precisa saber aonde encaixá las
bom voltando lá daquela minha segunda
história quando eu trilhei um novo
objetivo dentro das artes plásticas eu
definir que eu queria levar o meu
trabalho artístico para fora do brasil
então eu comecei listão 2 minhas cinco
habilidades
a primeira delas pintar a segunda
aceitar desafios a terceira correr atrás
a quarta tirar a idéia do papel ea
quinta fotografia e vídeo
como você pode ver a habilidade ela pode
ser tão do comportamental quanto técnica
e aí eu juntei duas daquelas habilidades
que era correr atrás e tirar a idéia do
papel e comprei uma passagem para
visitar uma feira na suíça eu tive uma
idéia eu vou percorrer a feira eu vou
levar o meu livro com as minhas obras
vão visitar galerias vou conhecer
pessoas e com certeza uma galeria
internacional vai querer me representar
lá fora
acontece que essa ideia ela não era tão
criativas em por que procurar uma
galeria na verdade é o caminho
tradicional que a maioria dos artistas
fazem dentro dessa área
e realmente não deu certo mas no meio
dessa viagem surge um encontro
o encontro com uma pessoa que me falou
assim a média se você tivesse mais tempo
aqui na suíça eu ia encomendar um quadro
de repente no meio daquela frase surgiu
uma oportunidade estampada pra mim que
era a possibilidade de pintar um quadro
na suíça
então eu agarrei aquelas duas outras
habilidades que eu tinha que era de
pintar e aceitável
fios e tive que pensar rápido ea partir
daquela oportunidade que surgiu daquele
encontro numa cidade que eu não tinha
nem tela nem tinta nem lugar para pintar
em cavalete nada se transformou em
apenas três dias num quadro de três
metros na suíça
quando eu vim hoje aqui eu enxerguei uma
oportunidade de trazer para vocês um
atalho que vai fazer vocês chegarem mais
rápido até o seu objetivo através de
idéias criativas
então o primeiro passo para a gente
conseguir implementar esse método é cada
um reconhecer as suas habilidades
vamos fazer o seguinte todo mundo pega o
celular de novo
vamos lá mas agora abrir no bloco de
notas
quando você abre no bloco de notas
escreve assim hashtag minhas cinco
habilidades
tudo junto né gente hashtag minhas cinco
habilidade e é você pula uma linha e
coloca um dois três quatro cinco mas não
preenche agora habilidade é algo que
você é bom e que você ama fazer então
começa a pensar sobre isso mas só copia
não preencha e aí depois você pula uma
linha e escreve assim posso te ensinar
alguma coisa nesta semana
preste atenção na força dessa frase
posso te ensinar alguma coisa nesta
semana quando você escrever isso você
vai estar dizendo o seguinte para as
pessoas
eu tenho esse conhecimento e eu tenho
disponibilidade para tim
na nessa semana seis entenderam a força
dessa frase agora pode guardar o celular
e vocês vão preencher isso só depois e
aí vocês vão pegar tudo isso que vocês
escreveram e vão levar para um lugar que
vai dar muita visibilidade
vocês vão apostar no digital
o digital conseguiu democratizar o
acesso e onde todas as pessoas têm voz e
possibilidade de alcance onde todo mundo
parte do mesmo ponto todas as contas um
dia tiver 10 seguidores
quando você aposta no digital coisas
incríveis podem acontecer e gente eu sei
que o verbo é pois tá né mas eu tô
falando de aposta mesmo não é colocar
dinheiro é você acreditar que aquele
post pode trazer algo que você nem
imagina
aí você deve estar se perguntando eu vou
ter que postar isso nas minhas redes
sociais vai se você tem duas redes pode
tem duas você tem cinco postos 15 se
quiser escrever só texto tudo bem se a
rede social precisar de foto coloca
alguma que represente você ou aquela sua
habilidade e não esquece da hashtag
minha cinco habilidades tudo junto
porque quando você usa uma gestão meg
você permite que outras pessoas têm em
conta e você também vai poder encontrar
outras pessoas e você vai ver que vai
ter gente interessada no que você tenha
ensinar e talvez você se surpreenda com
a quantidade de mensagens que você vai
receber ea partir dessas mensagens
dessas pessoas que têm interesse
naquelas habilidades que você tem
disponibilidade de ensinar
o seu próximo passo é marcar um encontro
o encontro mesmo e quando esse encontro
acontecerá dentro de uma semana
você ensina aquela sua habilidade que a
pessoa está precisando aprender
segundo a pirâmide de aprendizagem do
psicanalista americano william glacier
ensinar é a melhor forma de aprender é
quando você absorve a 95 por cento
daquele conteúdo ou seja ensinar vai te
fazer ainda melhor naquilo que você já
sabe há muito importante não esquece de
registrar esse encontro pode ser uma
foto ou uma self mesmo porque tem mais
uma coisa que eu vou te pedir ao júri
que ela é a última mas ela é muito
valiosa
você vai postar essa foto também junto
com a hashtag claro das minhas cinco
habilidades
depois que você fizer isso você não tem
idéia do que vai acontecer quando eu
voltei da suíça
eu peguei todos os registros que eu
tinha feito ali porque mesmo estando
sozinha com apenas três dias para pintar
um quadro sabia que era muito importante
registrar tudo como 10 como pudesse
então eu peguei todos aqueles registros
e apostei no digital e fui contam do
cada pedacinho daquela história que
tinha acontecido ali
o que aconteceu é que eu mesmo comecei a
dar mais valor para aquelas minhas
habilidades
comecei a descobrir umas outras também
que eu não tinha percebido que eu tinha
e aí eu fui combinando todas essas
habilidades e cheguei na seguinte ideia
criativa de um projeto
em que eu viajo o mundo pintando criando
uma imersão de arte na casa das pessoas
uma experiência que nunca ninguém
proporcionou no mundo da arte que tem
como resultado um quadro pendurado na
parede
depois que eu cheguei nessa idéia eu
sabia que ela ia me ajudar a chegar mais
rápido no meu objetivo que era levar o
meu trabalho para vários países do mundo
mas em paralelo a isso foi surgindo algo
aqui do meu lado
algo que eu não tinha percebido antes as
pessoas que vieram aqueles post que eu
fiz
começaram a reconhecer as minhas
habilidades e passaram a acreditar em
mim
e mesmo pessoas que eu não sabia que
podiam me ajudar a chegar no meu
objetivo
começaram a me apontar oportunidades e
essas pessoas ou que eu já conhecia ou
que passaram a me acompanhar no digital
viraram as linhas atuais conexões e você
lembra que eu disse lá na frente que
existem duas formas para você criar
atalho e chegar mais rápido no seu
objetivo que através de conexões e de
idéias criativas quando eu juntei esses
dois no meu projeto
ele voa para a malásia para a holanda
para outra cidade na suíça para a itália
e para os estados unidos
tudo isso em um ano
então talvez vocês não tenham percebido
ainda mas tudo o que vocês escreveram no
seu bloco de notas
é uma ferramenta uma ferramenta que vai
te ajudar a reconhecer as suas
habilidades vai fazer você ajuda a
alguém o que vai fazer ainda melhor
naquilo que você já sabe vai começar a
ti criar idéias criativas e vai começar
a construir a sua rede de conexões e só
o que você precisa fazer para isto
acontecer é esperar um sinal que vai
acontecer hoje à noite quando seu
despertador tocar se encontra mais tarde
estou apostando em vocês
[Aplausos]
[Música]